Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Bot Race
Now, this game game *blubbering*
Now this game came for the Ludum Dare Gamejam, and it features the saddest robot in the universe
From the Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
But, I don't know if that's a direct correlation
and I don't want to make any assumptions here
and also I-I think I need
Ah godamnit, I need- *screaming*
I NEED A XBOX CONTROLLER
GODAMNIT UGH I GOT SO MANY WIRES SORRY HANG ON
Couldn't find my godamn oosb*-cable (*USB)
Ba-dah-boop! Is it gonna plug in or do I gotta start the godamn game? Did it just restart my recording?
*muffled* BETTER NOT RESTART THE GAME
Alright, hi guys! Welcome back to the Bot Race, we're gonna get started now.
And the reason that I was drawn into this one is because it was so godamn adorable
because you can jump--and then you can shi-- ah fucking shit!
I don't know-- you didn't give me anything-- ah I should've looked at the controls, shouldn't I?
Okay--ah shit! Godamnit! He just smashed his face up against the glass--nooooo my little bunny
Okay, so once you get going, you don't stop going, and then you can--
oh shit, good god, how was anyone supposed to do that?
You sprint, and run, and jump around and BAM your way through glass
And then you also have a button that can make you shrink,
and you just turn into this adorable little bot,
going through this whole exercise, and it's awesome!
I mean, there's not a lot of--ho, there's not a whole lot of--oh god
AH (x4) AHHHHHHHHHH
Okay, ah ah oh fuck. OW GODAMNIT YOU'RE MAKING IT VERY DIFFCULT FOR MEEEEEE
It's randomly generated, so obviously it's going to be a bit of a problem, but
you can also *fart noise* EH *fart noise* AH FUCK
Hang on, lemme try this again, good god! Alright--hup, hup, HUP *fart noise*
Alright, there we go! Eh heh, eh heh heh,  eh heh heh heh AHHHHHHHH
AH! Oh god, man, that's a tough one, okay
It's fun, but anyway, I don't know how long I'm gonna be trying to play this, because, obviously
I've never been good at these endless runner games, and I don't know how
unrepetitive it's gonna be, and it just seems like waaay off in the distance you can see that
it's just kinda randomly generating, pulling up random pieces,
up from the abyss, and there's no end to this hallway. Or if there is an end,
I definitely don't know how to get to it, but it's a cute little game, and uh--it was just made for a gamejam
and the thing I love about these gamejam games is that if often explores, uh--different subjects
and each of the gamejams themselves have a theme! So, you'll have a theme and I believe  this one
was shapeshifting--*fart noise* It was shapeshifting, and it's just really interesting to see
how people put these interesting cooooooncepts *attempted fart noise* AHHHHAHHAHAHA
*insert more screaming here* DON'T MIND ME (x4) OH GOD *insert even more screaming here*
Awh, *chuckling*
I just fell down--*mumbling* ok, anyway
I'm gonna give it one more try--I'm gonna give it one more go--unless it's a pathetic attempt
and then I'm never gonna do it again.
but I'm trying to go over 1,000 meters distance
which is quite a hefty--*shudders* diffecence(?) in my opinion
I know there's probably some expert level players who did this already, but I'm merely an amateur
who just tries to have fun in life, so don't judge me for anything...
I'm just doing my thing
Concentration mode: ENGAGED
OH WAAAAAT WHY? WHY DID I DEFLATE?(x2)
I didn't--ah that's bullshit! Okay, trying to be--*fart noise*
*grunts* *blubbering* WHHHHY? WHY DID I DEFLATE?Why it doflade(?)
So, when you go over a single obstacle--oh geez(x2).
WHHHHHYYYY IT'S NOT LIKE I WANNA DO THAT
Alright, so I guess I gotta around them, cuz I think there's a--*stuttering*
I think the programing is like, if you pass over a single obstacle, it will force you to deflate
*fart noise* and then--so--but if I go around the outsides, I think I can kinda beat the system
and make it think that I'm not. *fart noise* (x2)
Whoooo okay, that was a tricky one, okay, so if I go around the outskirts...hahhhh la la la
See? *evil chucking* I know I can beat you...
I'm going for distance this time, now I wish, the only thing I wish there was
was there was a distance counter while I'm going through it
because it seems, like it's a little questionable, how far I get, before, I just end up dying
Hip, hip *fart noise*
*strange grunts* *fart noise*
Hahhhhh I beat you... eat a dick...(x2)
*weird grunts**fart noise*(are you okay markimoo)
*fart noise**squawking**more fart noises* Alright. We got this
WHOO I'M GOING FOR THE HIGH SCORE *fart noise*(x2)
WHAAAA *fart noise* AGHHHHHH oh geez(x2) oh we're getting faster! *fart noise*(x2) AGGHHHHHH
GODAMNIT NOOOOOO okay
Anyway, that is Bot Run! There's not a lot of *blubbering*
And there's not a whole lot to this game, but remember, it was made in 72 hours.
For a 72 hour game, this has a lot of polish! I mean, there's probably some bugs that I can exploit out of it
but it's surprisingly well put together, for a gamejam game!
So you can find this link in the description below, maybe you can beat my highscore,
I guarantee that you can beat my highscore, because I'm terrible at it.
But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching,
and as always, I will see YOU...
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!